honestly i think what the baby
said at best is ignorant at best is
ignorant
but really at the least it's just
exclusionary
like i wouldn't be mad if i went to a
concert with elton john he jamming his
songs bro and he's like hey if you suck
dicks make some noise as a man i
wouldn't be mad i just wouldn't make
noise right feel me i wouldn't be like
oh you know elton john excluded me in
these conversations bro stop trying to
always be included that's what's wrong
with america now they always want to act
like everybody needs to be included
that's not true you just don't need to
be discriminated against or necessarily
you know uh uh somebody being you know
bigoted you know prejudice right but i
don't got the [ __ ] with you
we so desperate to make everybody [ __ ]
with each other man [ __ ] that it's like
everybody wants to be
included in everything but isn't
necessarily don't got nothing to do with
you bro
my views as much as my views are liberal
i would never be with them [ __ ]
this [ __ ] like i i got way too much
attitude my my [ __ ] is too stand up and
conservatives at least they're just
[ __ ] feel me and i couldn't be that
cuz i don't have those views but i
respect that it's authentic and it's
from this is who we are versus somebody
y'all the same way but y'all trying to
act like y'all give a [ __ ] about